alive village was busy this afternoon
with an open house celebration and the
debut of a new mural honoring two lives
taken far too soon madison kimbrough
joins us live from hearts alive village
animal clinic with the very latest
tonight madison
yeah guests gathered here today to tour
the clinic for the first time since it
opened last november but a big draw was
also the unveiling of the tina tinter
and max mural that drew the crowd tinder
tina tinter and her dog max were killed
in a car crash in november after former
raiders player henry ruggs crashed into
them after driving under the influence
while tina's dog max was not a patient
of hearts alive village animal clinic
her family wanted to help out families
in need of affordable pet care and with
some of the money they received from
tina's go fund me they decided to use
some of those funds to donate to the
clinic creating the tina and max legacy
of love memorial fund christy stevens
with the hearts alive village says after
tina's family came forward with the idea
the clinic knew they wanted to
commemorate tina and max visually
having something like this really is
very meaningful
and we're so grateful to the family and
also just to be able to participate you
know tina was a major animal lover and
this is you know how they felt that they
could
you know
make their legacy meaningful
and ongoing tinter's family
was on site to see the unveiling and
several other animal lovers attended to
see the facility for the first time
hearts alive village has been active
since 2013 but it wasn't until november
of last year that they were able to open
up a clinic with boarding and full staff
the open house just ended a couple
minutes ago but the mural of max and
tina will live forever here at the
clinic reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now